did you think you were gonna talk more
japanese like be forced to when you
moved here
yeah yeah i i i i i thought he said
there was such remorse like because
it's so it's weird right because i think
everyone in my life expected me to as
did i
yeah but what ends up happening is that
i realized
okay i work from home uh i go to a
language school where all the staff
speak english
yeah um all my friends speaking places
yeah oh no
um i stream i i speak in english i go to
the gym i don't talk because
who the [ __ ] am i going to talk to
unless that whole guy talks to me yeah
i don't [ __ ] massive chat i told that
story i think i have right yeah yeah
so yeah there's actually like pretty
much no
time where i am i'm kind of the same as
well like right how often do you speak
japanese people outside of
business right um yeah i mean because of
covert i haven't been able to see my
family like
at all right right yeah and that as well
has made it even worse because strangers
don't want to [ __ ] talk to you
yeah exactly i mean like our neighbor
next to us
uh is like really [ __ ] cool old
couple and like every time i see them
like that i'll talk to them in japanese
but
i always get so nervous because the
moment i start talking to them
i can hear it in my inflection that like
oh no i'm [ __ ] like losing touch on
this [ __ ] like
i haven't been i haven't been serving
yet because i haven't been speaking
enough because all because the only time
i'll ever speak to
is like with my mom like an occasional
skype call or [ __ ] you know it's
weird right you live in japan
and you're like you're losing yeah yeah
so i have to you know i have to like
consciously
[ __ ] keep you know figuring out ways
of like okay
how can i use this language because if
there's one thing i don't want to lose
it's my japanese yeah
of course of course and here's the thing
about languages is that if you don't use
it
it'll get rusty and that's true with
like mai tai
as well yeah now that i'm like out of
shape yeah now that i'm living out of
thailand
i'm just like there's sometimes i'm
trying to remember entire world when i'm
speaking to my mom
and sometimes i get like the japanese
word instead because that's something
i've been
studying more recently it's really yeah
and it's it's weird to think
how little i can have to how little i
can use japanese and also live here you
know what i mean because
you kind of subconsciously find a way to
make it easy for yourself not gonna lie
the one actually like one thing i have
been starting to do recently is like
every time i read manga or a novel a
japanese novel or something i read it
out loud
just because because if i read it in my
head like of course i'm going to
understand it no no but
it's completely different like reading
and speaking skills is completely
different yeah
so i've like just kind of very quietly
read it to myself
yeah just to be just to remember like
okay that's how you pronounce that word
yeah it's like that for me like reading
welsh it's like getting confusing now
because i haven't done it in a long time
yeah yeah and it's a
i mean you've seen the wash language
right it's a [ __ ] jumble of sounds
it's like all right
that's why i don't understand you know
people who know like [ __ ] eight
languages
some people just have it man yeah it's
just it's crazy right like
i don't think inherently i i would ever
learn more than one language because i'm
i'm lazy as [ __ ] i'll be honest yeah
i mean the thing is like to try to pick
up a third is like [ __ ] my brain is like
connor we're really we're really going
to a limit here man really pushing it
but i don't think learning languages is
hard per se
i think it's just like okay if we just
all quit youtube tomorrow for like
like a year and just focus all our time
on actually learning this language
i think i feel like yeah we'd make like
so much progress but
what's hard about it is trying to learn
a language and fit it within
our already current lifestyle where
we're busy as [ __ ]
you know i mean i feel like that's the
real problem because it's
like i'm trying to find time where time
doesn't [ __ ] exist nowadays
where like it takes a lot of [ __ ]
time and dedication to that
and it's a long line between being able
to speak a language
conversationally and being fluent in the
way
the only time i've actually gotten like
able to get get proper
japanese practice is when we're [ __ ]
out on the lash or something we're at a
random barns like
like we're we're [ __ ] pissed out of
our heads that's just a random japanese
bloke who's as pissed as us
that's pretty much been like the best
language practice i've gotten since i've
moved here honestly yeah that probably
is
the best way to do it because because
you know if you're like a little
intoxicated then you're gonna be less
you know nervous i swear to god i speak
i speak any languages like ten percent
better and when i'm drunk except
english except english
[ __ ] man but i mean like languages from
what i've learned is like
learning a language and learning music
or like an instrument is the exact same
part of the brain
it's and they say like it's the exact
same with an instrument or language but
the second one is always going to be the
most difficult
and then from the third onwards it just
gets easier and easier and easier and
i guess for all for all three of us the
advantage is that we already know two
languages
quite formally so that's why and you
know you guys are learning a third right
so yeah it just puts pressure on me i'm
like
yeah you can actually learn a third
language as well i mean it's weird
because i don't
feel like i ever learned two languages
this is the first time i've
i felt like i've learned trying to
actively learn something where
rather than just like hey this is i just
knew this as a kid yeah
i didn't really think about it um
because you don't think about it in your
head when you speak tonight
because because the thing is it's just
like it is very much like learning and
learning an instrument it's just a lot
of it's like muscle
yeah i do not remember how i learned it
i don't remember
learning it yeah i just know that i've
always been able to understand it and
speak it that's why i hate it when
people ask me like
japanese language questions i'm like i
don't [ __ ] know how yeah yeah
yeah and it's also like when i and also
when you learn a language natively i
think you learn it wrong
you learn it locally and in a native way
yeah
people ask me some people would ask me
questions about welsh and i'd be like i
don't [ __ ] know
like i i just knew from speaking it yeah
i don't i don't know any of the rules i
i couldn't do half of them correctly
yeah
that's all that's why they say like the
best way to learn any language is to
live in the country that speaks it right
right right it's yeah i i don't know and
i i think i get a lot of questions about
like oh wait wait which language is
gonna speak well it's cause like i don't
really get much
use out of welsh so i don't really show
it off right yeah unfortunately because
it's
only spoken in uh wales and
one part of like south africa south
america there's like one
small place in somewhere in south
america where they speak welsh like a
town really
weird yeah a bunch of like welsh atlas
went there and we're like [ __ ] it let's
just make listen
let's chill here let's just do it that's
a shame because it's such a nice
language it sounds
[ __ ] long yeah it's so cool it's
always fun hearing people pronounce the
names of the towns
oh yeah yeah yeah isn't that that
buzzfeed video where i pronounce
like all the welsh names and it's
[ __ ] horrible they sound as cool as
they look as well oh yeah yeah because
like
my my dad can't speak welsh my mom could
speak welsh so my dad
[ __ ] butchers the the names and i
always just correct him
i just want to be an ass i'm like oh
yeah i do that to my dad with japanese
as well
i [ __ ] love doing music oh yeah it's
the same situation yeah it's like shut
up son
going back to the whole like trying to
fit it around your lifestyle there is
such a big part of me that's like [ __ ]
man i wish i could just take a year off
youtube and like
do it like perfect a skill but i'd get
like just do japanese class five years
ago yeah i've
i've like felt that definitely recently
where like my entire life has just
revolved around youtube for like the
past
four or five years and then i kind of
realized this last year
especially it was just like hey there
are other things i can do
with my life other than youtube and
learning japanese is definitely one of
them but
i really only have time to you know do
one
without making like substantial progress
on the other or just like making
almost zero progress i mean this this
covert situation definitely hasn't
helped considering that's really limited
where we can go right because i feel
travel as well even if you're traveling
with like a bunch of like
english-speaking people in japan
you just get into you can put yourself
into situations where you have to
interact with the locals right
yeah you know just travel is such a nice
way of just meeting people and like
getting to use the language as much as
possible because like
i feel there's less stress using a
language you're trying to learn while
you're traveling because yeah at the end
of the day yeah you're never going to
meet this person again
yeah i would have no qualms about like
butchering japanese to an old lady and
you get
[ __ ] nervous as [ __ ] trying to use
japanese at your local konbini right
because it's like i'm gonna see you
again probably tomorrow
same time oh my god and i don't want to
be remembered as that gaijin who can't
speak japanese right
as much there's a party that wants to do
that i'm like at the same time
i feel like i'm enjoying youtube now
more than ever oh yeah i'm enjoying
everything about it and it's going so
well that it would make
no sense to like yeah stop doing it yeah
yeah right like because
you know taking a year off youtube
although i could probably come back from
it i probably could
but is it worth the risk like no
probably not i can i can always learn
japanese later on in life which sucks
that i wouldn't have it now
and i would rather have it now but i
can't why not mix the two worlds
together
like make some kind of youtube content
about you learning japanese i considered
that but i thought that'd be such a big
undertaking and
i've seen language channels and they had
like drama
because they would like not end up
learning the language
no joke like david there was this video
where a guy made like an apology video
it was like technical drama yeah yeah so
like oh god
because you know when those videos went
around where it was like dude speaks 15
languages yeah
you're like well that's just absurd
but then i i started watching a lot of
those videos and i found like people who
were like their whole channel was about
them starting from zero
and then learning the language yeah yeah
yeah and there was like drama with this
one guy
because he was learning two languages at
once right i think it was like it was
like it was very different languages as
well
yeah and about halfway through like a
year in he's like you know what i'm
quitting i'm quitting swedish
you know i realized that it's just
hampering my progress trying to learn
two languages at once
right and all the it was like all the
comments were like what the [ __ ] man
i can't believe i believed in you like
your swedish was so good man
like and i was like oh my god anything
anything can be drama now and i just
thought like
if anything it would be a thing where i
would be like okay
let's see how much i can learn in three
months doing x a week right yeah and
then i would not announce it not make it
a prop not make it a series just
yeah here we go yeah yeah but at the
same time it also is a lot of pressure
that is like okay i gotta worry about
making other videos and also
actually learning japanese yeah
otherwise this video is gonna be a
little awkward if it's like
three months in i learn nothing
[ __ ] but that would be funny right like
it'll be like a funny conclusion to the
video
because i was because i had this video
idea where it's like because i've always
wanted to like improve more of my
japanese as well so i'm like
i can't just like commit like outside of
youtube or like outside of what i do and
all these side projects i do because i'm
just way too busy now
which sucks because i really do want to
like you know hone in on my japanese a
lot more
so i thought about like you know there's
like the kanji proficiency test yeah
yeah and i've got like
i got like the third highest on that but
like that was back in like high schools
but i'm like
i wonder if i can like go for the
highest one and
for the highest one uh i believe it's
three thousand
and i think only point four percent of
the population has it
yeah it's it's very like prestigious
yeah um but i thought like what if i did
a video where
is there a kanji for cultural
cross-pollination i guarantee you there
is a big one
don't worry but i thought to myself like
i wonder if i did a video where i just
like dedicated like a year
to just document myself like learning
that and trying to attempt for the test
but this isn't that scary though because
what if you don't make any progress like
six months ago that's
the only thing that's stopped and it's
also like in order for me
to in order for this video to be
successful i've got to [ __ ] grind
this [ __ ] yeah yeah and
if i do this and then the video flops
then that's just like
cool i wasted a year of my life for a
flopped video and a test that i failed
i think unlike the actual japanese
language i think you actually can like
gamify and speed run
kanji like i think kanji is speed
runnable i don't know man
it is dude totally playing explain
because you can
there's this like little apps that will
like [ __ ] whip you if you get it
wrong all right
so i i speed learned like a hundred
kanji
in like a day by doing that and i've i
know all of them now i can use them but
if i sat you down
and told you to write it out could you
write it out some of them
right but i'll read them yeah but this i
mean japanese oh read them
read them you should be able to read 100
kanji if i showed you 100
really 100 okay
challenge except i'm tempted to do a
live stream we're both streaming yeah
yeah
and i'll [ __ ] do a kanji test on you
the basic kanji
the hundred countries you know i'll do
i'll do a test 100 we'll do it okay okay
okay sounds like a video idea because
right you can you can gamify it
like and and you can start picking up
patterns and
i feel like the way that you can i don't
know like
at least when i was when i was learning
kanji i could easily pick up
kanji like i guess um because especially
living in japan right because
it wasn't like living in the uk sorry
where you learn this kind of g you would
leave your house you wouldn't see it
yeah
you leave your house in japan even if
you didn't talk to anyone
you see the kanji's everywhere yeah yeah
so you could keep practicing because you
keep seeing them like oh i know that oh
i know that
yeah you you do do that after like every
like trash day session yeah
we'll be catching the train you'll be
like what's that science say i've seen
that one before
yeah yeah yeah but i feel like that's
how that's the way you got to do it
right
right right right because that's that's
how a kid learns yeah it's like
inquisitive
yeah yeah problem is is where it starts
getting into like there's four kanjis
with four different
oh the same country with ten different
pronunciations and it's like oh this
which is like 30
of all kanji i love the ones with like
two i'm like